the 29 year old from colombia that is
julio tehran who they saw as an atlanta
brave many years ago
first season with the angels 10 and 11
last year with atlanta
and that's a call strike three on the
inside part of the plate that's that arm
angle that late movement run right on
the inside corner
olsen chilling butt they're on nice job
off the mound anticipating it a one two
three first
chamonic is on the bump this will be his
fourth start fastball
88-92 slider curve and pretty good
change up as well
trout's got great numbers it gets mania
seven for 19.
three home runs this one's in the dirt
gets by for murphy here comes fletcher
one nothing angels on the wild pitch
the angels have three straight hits and
that'll bring up anthony rendon
that is sky high deep toward the corner
and left field moving over
robbie grossman near the wall gone big
fly for anthony rendon a two-run shot
three-nothing angels
[Applause]
chapman's got it fires to second for one
plenty of time on the first and that's a
double play so
nyah gets out of the industry chapman
hitting 246 with the 290 on base
percentage has four home runs
the pitch to chapman on the way into ron
a fastball high fly ball
left center field deep upton will turn
and watch it
fly and these are on the board on a
second inning home run by chapman
and it's now three to one angels and
these keep the line moving
as they are first and second and nobody
out and piscotty's coming up
scotty slices one toward the right field
line that's a fair ball
cannon racing around third cannon is
going to come in to score
and now it's three to two simeon with
two out in the ass down by a run
to the backstop biscotti hustling in
he will be safe in this ball game's tie
broken bad roller toward third run
doanes got it he'll go the short way
and they force out simeon 3-3 bottom of
the second and justin upton leads up
here's the pitch by manaya the 2-2
off speed swung on and missed mania
retired the first two in the inning now
the next two have gotten on and tommy
listello will bat you know one hopper
caught on the line by olsen takes it
right off the dirt at first base and the
inning is over
here's matt chapman he's hoping in three
consecutive games now
that one's hit to center that's deep
trout's back and
that baby's gone matt chapman has over
twice in the first three innings and the
a's have a 5-3 lead
man andres is called upon here to clean
up julio tehran's mess in the third
inning
called strike three got him looking on
the inside part of the plate
got him upstairs oh ran the fastball
above the zone
back-to-back strikeouts for matt two
down now the one-two
and pender strikes out how about it man
andres comes in strikes
out the three batters albert grounded
into a double play his first time up
strikeout or ground ball is what shawn
manaya needs
and that one is line chapman with a
great diving play
unbelievable so two home runs three rbis
takes away
probably two runs there defensively so
that's five runs he's involved in
matt chapman count is evened up up to
hits one toward the middle simming to
his left can't come up with it a run
will score
5-4 oakland we're in the third that's
going to load them up for joe adele
and he threw a fastball right by adele
that is how the integral end the angel
sent seven to the plate
the a's have loaded the bases and
that'll bring matt chapman to the plate
chapman drives one right center field
nobody's gonna get it
bounces off the wall one run scores here
comes loriano
and loriana will score as well all three
runs score and chapman ends up at third
have a night eight to four the a's lead
cannon hits a high fly ball shallow left
center field upped in a long run upton
had it in his glove popped out
chapman's gonna come in to score and
ending up at second base is kenna
so it's nine to four trout on board
twice with a couple of singles that he's
also scored twice
that is hammered out to left field no
doubt about it big fly for mike trout
two run shot the angels creep a little
bit closer now in this spa game it's
9-6 oakland angels second and third
one out chopper toward the middle simeon
comes in on it
the run will score and it's nine to
seven javits multi-homer game
at a bases loaded triple line towards
short that's gonna turn into a double
play
lorianno got hung up on that ball that
was squared up it was almost got that
triple play on that one
that ball was scalded will be the tying
run coming to the plate
that is drilled out to right center
field l'oreal is going to watch it go
big fly ohtani-san we're tied at nine
third home run for the halos and another
home run with someone on
base out of the stretch and the 2-1
pitch is
dribble back toward the mount trevino to
the first space side has it a flip to
first in time but the damage done
see your truck can capitalize at a great
game already three for four
score three runs two run home run that
is hammered out to left field
no doubt about it he's done it again big
fly
for mike trout and the angels are on top
10 to nine
what a game for trout ty butchery is on
in relief
trying to close it out for the angels
out toward left field brian goodwin's
got to go back on it
still moving back light that baby up as
he makes the catch and the angels pick
up the victory tonight by the final of
10-9 what an outstanding comeback